faire passer un message à travers sa
photo
Anne-Lise Siegler passionné de l'Inde
mais surtout passionné par les
rencontres qu'elle y a faites concours
un peu par hasard au prix Célimène
j'avais envie de remporter le Prix pas
forcément pour moi mais pour le message
que les livrer cette photo parce qu'il y
a un message pour moi qui était assez
engagé qui portait à la réflexion sur le
statut en fait la position de la femme
en Inde un message sur la condition de
la femme en Inde d'un côté le modernisme
d'une société en mouvement et de l'autre
le voile de la tradition au début quand
je fais cette photographie j'ai pas
voulu montrer quoi que ce soit en
particulier parce que je me promenais
dans une rue et j'avais mon appareil
photo et je prenais des clichés mais à
la prise de vue je me suis rendu compte
qu'en fait il y avait ce mouvement de
verticalité et qui avait cette
opposition que retrouver un peu dans
dans la société indienne qui est assez
complexe enfin l'un des villes l'un des
campagnes les femmes là qui sont plus
dans une OP
traditionnels qui sont plus libérés ou
plus modernes quelque part un cliché un
état des lieux qui interpelle le jury et
la suite de l'histoire et forcément
belle m'attendais pas du tout à recevoir
un prix enfin comme je vous l'ai dit ça
s'est passé à la dernière minute ma
participation c'est absolument pas prévu
et donc c'était une très belle surprise
encore une fois
pas forcément pour moi mais pour le
message que je voulais véhiculer pour
attirer l'attention et la réflexion sur
cette problématique là un premier prix
qui débouche tout naturellement sur une
expo
dans la démarche artistique et mais par
contre ça m'a crédibilisé c'est sûr que
ça m'a donné un crédit un poids dans mes
autres démarches et j'ai réalisé une
exposition photo l'année dernière aussi
une pratique de la photo non
professionnel qui s'ajoute à d'autres
démarches artistiques c'est un roman qui
est inspiré de mon vécu en Asie durant
quatre ans de 2005 et 2010 notamment un
en Chine un Sri Lanka et 2 ans et demi
en Inde donc c'est un petit peu un
vagabondage spatio-temporel sur
plusieurs espaces sur plusieurs temps
aussi puisque ce livre a été écrit entre
2100 et 2010 l'horizon d'annemise est
toujours tourné vers l'Inde avec les
femmes au centre de son inspiration son
dernier voyage dans ses contrées
lointaines remontent à juin 2013 elle a
désormais hâte d'arpenter le pays pour
amener ses expressions qui pourraient
sont uniques